whose land is this
my land
well well well our war hero has arrived
you've been a good choice going back
here this is our the finest wealthiest
and most beautiful people on God's Earth
they outsmarted everybody
they have the same
against the oil
son I got a question you like women
that's my weakness
well we mix these families together and
that state money flows the right
direction it'll come to us
that's how you are I don't know what you
said but it must have been Indian for
handsome devil fish
[Music]
why did you come here
you're scared of him
oh easy
he's the nicest man in the world
the Osage their time is over
we've got to chase back control of our
home
I was in down from Washington DC to see
about these murders
we have so many deaths we've lost count
let's just man look seems more like an
epidemic than bad luck to me
[Music]
don't say just die by the enemy
do not let them die alone
evil surrounds my heart
yeah
I pick a side
[Music]
I don't even know if you love me anymore
kill these men who killed my family
did your wife say who she was most
afraid of
[Applause]
it into something you might have regret
for the rest of your life
[Applause]
[Music]
I ain't got nothing but a grip